Ali is an asylum Seeker from Iran who
crossed the channel on a small boat last
year he says it was a terrifying
experience
every second every moment we are
expecting a bad happening a bad incident
because you are like it like a small
Point small dot at the middle of nowhere
with all of big fairies big uh cargo
ship ships and stuff so we were so
scared
when you heard the news
what had happened to the people on the
channel what went through your mind they
have lots of hopes lots of plan for rest
of them life and the cruel Channel
killed them
it's not the first time Ali is mourning
the deaths of fellow Asylum Seekers he
was friends with five members of the
Kurdish Iranian nejad family who
perished in the channel two years ago
the mother of family sent me uh sent me
a voice message and told me all of the
smokers
are so bad people and they were thinking
they are thinking about money only money
not Humanity
the government is clear about who's to
blame
crossing the channel in unseaworthy
vessels is a lethally dangerous endeavor
it is for this reason above all that we
are working so hard to destroy the
business model of the people Smugglers
evil organized criminals who treat human
beings as cargo
that campaigners say Boat Crossings are
being driven by the lack of safe and
legal routes for genuine Asylum Seekers
to reach the UK
it is simply not possible in most
circumstances for someone fleeing
persecution or a war-torn country to
wait for a fictitious scheme which may
or may not come in time to sometimes
save their lives or the lives of their
families or loved ones it is not a
compassionate approach
those who've made it to the UK say
people understand how dangerous the
journey is but it won't stop them from
Crossing Lisa Holland Sky News